-Guys, I'm so
excited about this.
Rachel Maddow
is my guest tonight!
-Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Rachel will break down th
South Carolina primary,
walk us through Super Tuesday,
and tell us about
the coronavirus.
And by the end of her segment,
Democrats will be like,
"Can she just be the nominee?"
That's right -- Saturday was the
South Carolina primary,
and by Sunday night,
Pete Buttigieg
dropped out of the race.
Buttigieg said he was
ending his campaign to,
"Help bring the party
and our country together."
Yeah. With that
kind of attitude,
it's clear he wasn't
presidential material.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I feel badly that Buttigie
is out of the race,
especially since the president
spent so much time
trying to learn his name.
-Boot-edge-edge.
Boot-edge-edge.
You say "boot"
and then add "edge-edge."
Boot-edge-edge.
Boot-edge-edge. Boot-edge-edge
Boot-edge-edge!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But it wasn't just Buttigieg.
Tom Steyer also dropped ou
of the race.
He said, "I can't see a path
where I win the presidency."
It probably would have helpe
if that wasn't
also his campaign slogan.
"I can't see a path
where I win the presidency."
It's just basic.
But it didn't stop with
Buttigieg and Steyer,
because just a few hours ago
Amy Klobuchar also dropped out
Amy said, "Even after all
of that Klomentum,
I've decided to Klo away."
-Oh.
-But this is interesting.
Klobuchar dropped out and
immediately endorsed Joe Biden
At the end of her speech,
she said,
"I'm Vice President
Amy Klobuchar,
and I approve this message."
We know.
We know what you're doing.
That's right -- the big winner
in South Carolina was Joe Biden.
In fact, I heard that
he even got a
congratulatory phone call from
President Obama.
But when Biden asked for
Obama's endorsement,
he was like, "Uh...I'm going
through a tunnel.
Uh...my phone's at 2%.
No habla Inglés."
During his rally in
Houston today,
Joe Biden tried to quote the
Declaration of Independence,
but I think he had a littl
trouble with it. Watch.
-We hold these truths to b
self-evident.
All men and women created by -
You know the --
You know the thing.
-What? What?
Later, Biden was like, "I pledge
allegiance to the -- Whatever.
Everybody knows
what I'm talking about."
As soon as they saw that,
Buttigieg, Steyer, and Klobuchar
all jumped back into the race.
There you go.
Trump saw that
and was like, "Damn.
Game recognize game."
But tomorrow is Super Tuesday,
and it looks like Bernie Sanders
could win big
in California and Texas.
When asked about Super Tuesday
Bernie said, "Soup or Tuesday?
Soup or Tuesday?
I'll have the soup!"
Alright.
That's right -- a lot of
people are saying that
we're down to a two-man race
between Bernie and Biden.
Can we see those two? Yeah
Usually, guys like that
only fight over
the last large-print copy of
"Reader's Digest."
That's right -- we're one
slip and fall away
from having a one-man race
Meanwhile, this weekend,
President Trump
showed up at CPAC and
started talking about
how Elizabeth Warren took down
Mike Bloomberg at the debates.
He even included a new
impression of Bloomberg.
Watch this.
-She was really mean to
Mini Mike.
I'll tell you,
the way she treated him.
He didn't know what hit him.
He's going, "Oh, get me off of
this stage.
Get me off!
Get me off of this stage!"
-Trump spent two days workin
on that impression
and two minutes working
on the coronavirus.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Everyone is still talking abou
the coronavirus,
and now New York has
its first confirmed case.
And you can tell New Yorkers are
real worried because
the price of "Hamilton" ticket
dropped to just $9,000.
I mean, it's rough out there
But the CDC has been
reminding everyone
to wash their hands for
20 seconds,
or, as they call it,
the time it takes to sing
"Happy Birthday" twice.
Apparently, measuring
the time in popular songs
is working, because today,
I saw this new commercial
from the CDC.
Check it out.
-The Centers for Disease Control
presents "Hand-Washing Hits,
a collection of
classic 20-second songs
to scrub your hands to.
You'll get hundreds of hits,
like "'Happy Birthday'
Sung Twice."
"'Take Me Out to the Ball Game
Just Once."
"The 'Seven Nation Army' Rif
Hummed Five Times."
"The Guitar Part in
'Sweet Child O' Mine'
Before Axl Rose Starts Singing."
"Four We will,
We Will Rock You."
"The Really Long 'Daaaay' in
Phil Withers' 'Lovely Day.'"
"The Bradley Cooper-Lady Gag
Harmony Part
at the end of 'Shallow.'"
DJ Khaled Saying 'Another One'
Twenty Times."
And many more.
Order today and get a bonus CD
of hand-washing songs
for kids, "Quarantine Bop.
Call now.
-"Quarantine Bop"?
-Goodness.
-And, finally, I read abou
a man in Ohio
who gave up for a food for Len
and said
he's only drinking beer.
I think the guy might have
a drinking problem
because he's actually Jewish
We have a great show!